couple of middle-aged white men just
lost their jobs and that's a good thing
generally it's bad when middle-aged
white guys lose their jobs in America
but this time it's pretty good
Adam Schiff and Eric swalwell just lost
their jobs on the house intelligence
committee this because the Republicans
took over the house Kevin McCarthy's The
Speaker of the House Kevin McCarthy said
listen jerks both of you guys are off
the Intel committee you shouldn't have
security clearances you shouldn't be
around any kind of sensitive information
uh Schiff you're a liar who who has
mishandled classified information for
the entire Trump presidency and swalwell
you were doing weird stuff with the
Chinese spy so neither of you guys can
be trusted
Hakeem Jeffries who's the Democrat
minority leader in the house he came out
he said this is a a shocking upsetting
of precedent you can't do this that the
tradition the precedent in the house is
that the minority party gets to name the
people that it wants to the Committees
and then the speaker of the house is
supposed to accept that
this is awful he says it's my
understanding that you intend to break
with the long-standing house tradition
of deference to the minority party
you you were you should honor past
practice
I'm glad to hear Hakeem Jeffries and the
libs mention honoring past practice
for once in their entire lives
this Ring's so Hollow do the libs honor
anything about the Pat the libs hate the
past the libs spend all their time
tearing down statues of the past and
talking about how evil the past was and
how anything that is traditional or
conservative is just terrible and we
need to upend the whole thing
except for this except for Adam Schiff
and Eric swallow staying on the Intel
committee that that's just that's the
one historical precedent that we need to
keep I don't think so I think this is
chickens coming home to roost is what I
think this is and I think that when the
Democrats when Pelosi set up the
Preposterous January 6 committee
to investigate the worst thing that ever
happened in American history and and the
Republicans said okay we're going to
send some Republicans to this committee
then we're going to name Jim Jordan I
forget who the other uh Republican
Congressman who's going to go to that
committee were the
the house said nope
Pelosi said no you're not going to do
that we're not going to let you have any
actual Republicans we're going to name
the Republicans it's going to be it's
going to be Liz Cheney and Adam
kinzinger who aren't real Republicans
who are for all intents and purposes
Democrats
oh but now this is the great upsetting
of oh no this is terrible okay well I
guess Hakeem Jeffries just made a slight
Progressive out of me because I think
that's one historical tradition that
that's gone and even if it was a good
tradition the Democrats are the ones who
blew it up and now I don't want to hear
them whining about the chickens coming
home to roost Republican Congressman
Marjorie Taylor Greene
is set to get new committee positions
this is a big comeback for MTG because
she had previously been kicked off of
the Committees
uh now the GOP house steering committee
voted to give Marjorie a seat on the
house Homeland Security committee this
is a minor Personnel issue so I don't
want to spend too much time on it but
it's an important one because it shows
you how politics works
the the Nitty Gritty nuts and bolts of
Politics the reason that Marjorie made a
comeback is because she backed Kevin
McCarthy
and she backed Kevin McCarthy in that
house fight
over her fellow conservatives in the
freedom caucus who were opposing
McCarthy
and it was it was a real tough fight
here and a lot of people wondered they
said why is Marjorie Taylor green who is
one of the more conservative members of
the House certainly one of the more
outspoken conservatives why is she
backing a guy who's who's being called
establishment
this is why
because it was the only way that she
could get any
even marginal power back in the House of
Representatives
and some people have attacked her for it
and said well that's unprincipled
but I don't know that it's totally
unprincipled Kevin McCarthy was likely
going to win anyway she realized this
was her only path back
now she's on a committee
I I'm almost certain Kevin McCarthy said
the only way that you were getting on a
committee ever again is by backing me
and whipping some votes for me
and it brings me back to a principle
that old cocaine Mitch McConnell love
him or hate him he made a very good
point
he said the way politics works is
the winners go and make laws and the
losers go home
[Music]
say hello to my little friend that's
what he said he said at least the first
part is what he said and that's true
until politics works
now Marjorie green she's got a little
bit of power back hope she uses it well
I trust that she will use it well you
know what today is today is woke
Wednesday the rest of the show continues
now
there is a very
uh thought-provoking woke reaction that
Mr Davies and the other producers want
me to
to process and give my expert analysis
on
you only get that on the member segment
so to become a member today use code
Knowles to check out kwles that's
dailywire.com
Slash nulls use code nulls you will get
two months free on all annual plans
[Music]